EU ministers for transport will work to
reach a general approach on the two
proposals to make the European air
transport system more efficient and to
further develop the single European sky
initiative launched in 2004 the SES
initiative aims to improve the
competitiveness of the European air
transport sector it would help overcome
the current fragmentation of the air
space and optimize the use of air
traffic management capacity on rail
transport the council will seek a
general approach on a proposal to repeal
the current regulation on accounts of
railway undertakings which has become
obsolete the objective is to eliminate
inconsistencies in the EU legal order
reduce red tape and ensure equal
treatment of companies ministers will
also take stock of the progress of to
other proposals aimed at improving rail
services in the EU by means of market
opening and stronger governance a set of
conclusions on transport infrastructure
and the trans-european network will be
adopted these conclusions will
contribute to the midterm review of the
Europe 2020 growth strategy scheduled
for 2015 ministers wish to point out the
contribution of the transport
infrastructure sector to growth and jobs
creation finally ministers will be asked
to agree on a decision to authorize
Member States to become parties of the
International Convention on standards
for fishing vessel personnel this
convention is the first attempt to make
safety standards for crews of fishing
vessels mandatory worldwide